es oficial es Shakira se sentada en el
banquillo de los acusados en la juez de
instrucción de esplugas de llobrega
cerca de Barcelona lo confirmó esta
mañana habla juicio contra la cantante
colombiana por seis delitos fiscales ya
que ella y la fiscalía no llegaban a
ningún acuerdo ya que la cantante se
niega a declararse culpable por estos
delitos está acusada de haber defraudado
14,5 millones de euros a la hacienda
española al no declarar ningún impuesto
sobre la renta ni tampoco sobre el
patrimonio entre 2012 y 2014 cuando en
las autoridades consideran que ella
residía aquí habitualmente pero la
cantante dice que no es verdad que en
esta época estaba de gira en mundial
casi todo el año y Por ese motivo no se
la podía considerar que se identifica
fiscal en España pero la fiscalía pide
puestos delitos hasta ocho años de
cárcel 24 millones de multa Shakira
postulado considera que no hay cometido
estos delitos y dice que tiene las
pruebas de su inocencia y que los
llevará al juicio que tenga lugar en los
próximos meses en Barcelona